obviously people need a code of ethics
but we need to appreciate that right now
there are four thousand companies that
have signed on to the UN guidelines
every single major corporation has
ethics and values statements that their
board of directors sign so signing
statements is not an indication of
compliance rules aren't self regulated
so to let corporate executives off the
hook by simply signing a piece of paper
is more about changing image than change
a reality and only when they're
accountable only when we deal with toxic
assets in the same way we deal with
toxic products which is prosecuting
people who abuse their values and their
authority will we be able to make the
kind of changes we need so I totally
believe in a code of ethics but it has
to be accountable responsible and
enforced by everyone outside the
corporation by governments and
independent third parties